give yourself up Carla why would I do
that
[Laughter]
give yourself up Carlo
[Laughter]
shut up [ __ ] come out there's my big
[Music]
none of the games call though
the games are just oh you are under
arrest for the murder of Mary Deely meg
Foster and one detective Mason Jimenez
now where's the girl
Oh detective oh you assume it's the real
me standing in front of you but maybe
that's just what I want you to see when
in reality the real me is safe in a
hiding spot that's the real you all
right
or maybe I'm over here no no you're not
over there Carlo I'm only gonna ask you
one more time where is the girl go ahead
and shoot detective I mean what do I
care if you get seven years bad looking
you know it's not safe to keep a gun
cocked like that even if you are just
pointing it didn't hurt
turn around and put your hands on your
head now for that you really are going
you have to find your real not you came
oh it's you I'm holding your lapel now
you're done it's over you're gonna cook
your hand on that broken mirror where is
she dude say what so you don't know
whether or not this is the real me or
just a reflection in a mirror
really
okay I don't know whether the you I'm
holding on to is really you for the
reflection or reflection in the mirror
oh she's under the floorboards on the
entrance
I win detective I told you but I mean
the mirror told you but well you know
you